you promise to rebuild five hospitals by
2030 because they're full of this
particular kind of concrete that will
make them now fall down
um some of the other hospitals that you
promised to rebuild are now going to be
delayed so what about the other 29 that
the NHS has already identified as liable
to collapse well we were clear in our
Manifesto we were going to build 40 new
hospitals and the statement on Thursday
made clear that that's exactly what
we're going to do but of course what NHS
leaders have said to us is those five
black hospitals as you say the ones with
concrete where there is a risk a risk to
the building fabric it's right that we
prioritize those so of course we're
following the evidence and the evidence
shows that those five hospitals are
priority cases it's right we respond to
those the ones that are then impacted by
that are still part of the new hospitals
program it's just they may not be
complete by 2030 which is the original
Target date we set in the manifesto so
we're committed to those hospitals
they're still part of the program we'll
be working on them and sorting enabling
works on those schemes but it's right we
prioritize the rack hospitals because
there's a an urgent need to do so so to
be clear and there's no shame in this
you are not going to fulfill your 2019
Manifesto pledge of 40 new hospitals we
are going to by 2030. we are going to
fulfill it by 2030 that's what we were
very clear the five hospitals are coming
into that scheme which will be completed
and I'll tell you how it's by embracing
modern methods of construction in a
similar way to the way that we have in
education in the ministry of Justice
with prisons as is common in the private
sector to building much more in
factories using modern methods of
construction that speeds up the approval
I get of those schemes but also the
construction time of those games
bringing those into the program I get
all that you can do you can do new
things I started life as an engineer so
I knew things move on but just to be
clear I thought you just said that you
would not be able to make build those
29 other new hospitals to get your
target to 40
by 2030. will there be 40 new hospitals
by 2030 or not right there will be 40
hospitals by twenty two hospitals 20 of
these schemes in the program will start
construction next year a number already
have and will they be completed by 2030.
the commitment is for 40 new hospitals
by 2030 we're bringing in the rack
hospitals within the scheme because
independent reports
involved she wrote very sent Emmons
they're urgent and we need to address
those so just to be clear all 40 are
going to be uh spanking new hospitals
open for business by 2030. there'll be
40 new hospitals in line with the
announcement in 2020 where there was a
number of cohorts cohorts two three and
four the cohort one schemes were already
underway those schemes will now proceed
the cohort 2 schemes for example someone
is telling me that they'll be ready by
2030. well I think I'm being clear there
will be
seems complete by 2030 they will include
the five rack hospitals there were some
within the list that will be part of a
rolling program that will go beyond but
that's because five have been added to
the 40. all right we could go on about
the the chop the words for for all
morning
if it's helpful indeed indeed so um
the the problem with with this pledge is
that you did say you'd build this 40 new
Hospitals now telling me it's gonna
happen you originally said that there'd
been eight of them built by 2025 so far
you've managed two
it's not that persuasive that uh you're
going to build the 40 by 2030 given that
you haven't even got the eight by 2025.
it's a very fair Challenge and let me
explain why we're changing our approach
as a result nine of the last 10
hospitals built in England where over
time and over budget and that's because
what quite often happens is as the
schemes starts the specifications are
changed people come along with their
bells and whistles and want to change
what's in the scheme by taking more time
and having a standardized approach
What's called the model 2.0 hospital so
a standardized approach that allows us
to bring all that expertise into one
design then go out to Market and have
the economies of scale that the NHS
offers and this is something that's very
common in the private sector we've
already done it in education and in
prisons it is a fundamentally different
approach for how the NHS will build its
buildings but that's how we will
accelerate the program by using modern
methods all right instruction okay we
will revisit this or somebody who's
sitting here will revisit this with you
in a year's time
um now the RCN annual conference Pat
Cullen general secretary said that you'd
emailed her and agreed to me how did
that meeting go oh we had a very
constructive meeting uh this week uh
working with Pat Pat obviously was
deeply involved in the original
negotiation she recommended that deal to
her own members she said that it
constituted real they said no though
well she negotiated the deal with me and
the rest of the staff Council she said
it was real progress uh tangible uh no
more what she said her members said they
didn't like it they want more than 10
are you going to give it to them well
the NHS staff Council agreed to the deal
so the majority of Health unions
accepted uh the AFC bill that's why that
will go into pay packets uh in June
because we hugely value the work that
NHS staff do that's why
she said there's going to be more
strikes uh this morning are you saying
to Pat Cullen doors open we're we're
going to move towards you to your art
Target more than 10 or are you saying to
her
look you know the the staff Council
decided this you're getting the money
that's it forget it I'm saying what Pat
herself said which was it's not there
and finally you have to ask for you what
you're saying and and being consistent
and what Pat said at the time that the
deal went to members was exactly the
same as what I said and what the rest of
the NHS staff Council said which was as
a fair and final settlement a five
percent uh pay increase plus a lump sum
it means a band Six uh entry nurse gets
over five thousand pounds over the two
years recognizing the huge valuable
contribution that NHS staff have made
okay what some in the RCN I'm asking
this to do isn't legally possible it's
not possible to give a band Six nurse a
different pay to a band Six Midwife or
against six paramedic because they're
great so they're rated the jobs that
they evaluated in the same way but Pat
herself said this was real progress she
recommended the deal
we all know what Pat said but what
matters is what her members said and
they said they do not like the deal that
you've negotiated that has been accepted
by the staff Council they are a big
Union and what about a third one
yeah whatever it vote and is a small
number whatever Pat may or may not have
said to you in your meeting the point is
her members don't like it and what
you're telling me and I'm uh forgive you
know tell me I'm wrong the words I've
picked out of your answer there are full
and final what you're saying to them is
that's your lot well we're going to make
that payment in tune to all uh over a
million uh you've told me that but this
is that you're you're not going back to
negotiating table with the RCN well not
on the amount of pay there's things in
the deal that we agreed with the NHS
staff Council where there is further
work around pay progression uh around
violence against staff around pension
abatement there's various things with
within the deal and we've agreed a
package of work with the NHS staff
Council to take those forward but this
is something that the stuff comes up as
a whole voted on unions like Unison over
70 supported this deal and we will get
this payment out to people in their June
settlements okay
um one of the other things uh in that
discussion with the nurses is the long
delayed Workforce plan which you
promised in November 2018 any chance
we're ever going to say that well the
chancellor committed to the long-term
Workforce plan in the Autumn statement
uh it is a big complex set of proposals
it's right that we take our time to get
the detail of that right we will bring
that out uh soon but it needs when it's
soon four and a half years is not soon
well it was announced in the Autumn
statement that we would bring this
forward obviously
had a pandemic and various things that
have been happening in recent years but
the Autumn statement gave a commitment
from the chancellor to have a long-term
Workforce plan it's something that
colleagues in NHS England have been
working intensely on we need to look at
both the additional numbers and how we
grow our domestic domestic Workforce but
also what reforms we can put in in terms
of using our skills mixed better using
new roles within and within the NHS in
different ways so it is a complex piece
of work it's right we take our time to
get it uh as it should be but we will
bring that out very soon I I respect
your your answer but when you say take
your time you've already taken four and
a half years the Chancellor's committed
okay fine is the chancellor committed to
paying the money that any Workforce plan
that's to go into the detail but it's
going to cost you money has he committed
to paying for it well of course any
expansion of domestic Workforce will
come at a cost as a cost in terms of the
the training itself there's cost from
higher numbers in terms of the the pay
for those roles as well but it's also
about looking at what reforms we can
bring forward as part of that plan but
of course these are discussions we have
on a cross-government basis and that
will be part of the announcement so
secretary I can sort of hear a sound
there and it feels like the sound the I
say with cans being kicked down the road
again now I'll be very clear the plan
will come out very shortly it will be
shortly before the next specific date
well yeah before the next day absolutely
very shortly uh but I'm not going to
give a date this morning it's a huge
amount of work has gone in so guys uh
and uh you know it's something that
we're having discussions on as we speak
okay the chancellor has appeared in our
conversation already this morning
um he said to my colleague Ed Conway uh
Sky's data and economics editor on
Friday uh when Ed asked him if he was
comfortable with Bank of England doing
whatever it takes to bring down the
inflation even if it precipitates a
recession Jeremy Hunt said yes because
the inflation is a source of instability
there's nothing automatic about bringing
down inflation it's a big task but we
must deliver it and we will your last
job I think was in the treasury
recession is a price worth paying you
okay with that well we're being clear
the prime minister just as five key
commitments includes growing the economy
and I was very pleased to see that the
RMF rated uh our growth 0.7 uh increase
so we do need to have inflation we need
to grow the economy and we need to
reduce debt and that is why those are
the first three key commitments from the
prime minister in terms of because five
pledges even if it means a recession
with attendant levels of unemployment
impact on living standards and indeed by
the way uh impact on public spending
which means you probably won't get the
money that you want from the treasury
that's all fine or acceptable if it
brings down inflation no if it brings
down what I'm saying is we need to grow
the economy that's the second of the
prime minister's commitments and the IMF
said that the chancellor had acted
decisively that was reflected in the up
rating of our growth forecast from the
RMF just this week so growing the
economy is one of the prime minister's
five pledges we're committed to doing so
just as we are to cutting waiting time
so my focus in terms of the health
secretary through announcements this
week like on patient Choice empowering
patients Association saying that to take
three months of people's waiting times
that's what we're focusing
we've got a glimpse of honesty from from
the chancellor uh
Mr sunax pledge one bring down inflation
pledge to bring raise growth sometimes
those two things are going to be in
conflict and the Chance has been very
honest he says
inflation is number one target for a
reason and if that means you know that
we have a recession so be it doesn't
want it but it might be why can't you
say the same well do you disagree with
him you started you started the
interview talking about the cost of the
new hospitals program and clearly one of
the areas where inflation has an impact
is on construction costs building
materials uh double digit increase at
the moment so the impact on inflation is
important to the NHS but what we have
seen from the Prime Minister and from
the chancellor is their commitment to
funding the NHS 6.6 billion contributed
at the Autumn statement additionally to
the NHS and most importantly up to 7.5
billion for adult social care because
how we integrate Health and Social care
is hugely important so priority at the
Alton statement was Health and Social
care funding and we can't make that
problem let's just get to the number of
what the difficulty is here all this
means borrowing and the cost of
borrowing is climbing
um we had a look at the uh the bond
yields uh and here we can see it look
you're up to uh get four point four and
a third percent now which if I if I read
it rightly this is the highest April
figure for borrowing cost since
1997. you are not going to be able to
afford any of this because of the boring
course are you well as I say the RMF uh
commented this week that the chancellor
has started appeal to the IMF because
you every time they just say that that
you're in trouble you say what a load of
rubbish they are let's just deal with
what usually you quote them in the
interview so I don't I'm not coaching
them I'm just responded I didn't quote
them this is your numbers but my focus
as health secretary is so you get the
waiting times down round and that is
what we're doing if you look at the
contrast between our approach in England
which is working where two-year weights
were eliminated virtually in the summer
uh 18 month Waits down below 11 000. if
you look at the contrast where in Wales
it was 74 000 for 18 weeks
obviously is looking at the economic
side but what we're doing on the health
side but the point is you were
responsible at one point for this role
and you know with boring costs at that
level the chancellor cannot do all the
things that you've just been talking
about well that's why the Prime Minister
set out the five pledges he has in terms
of halving inflation growing the economy
reducing that but the fourth one is the
one that and the core inflation went up
the fourth one is the one core inflation
went up from I think 6.2 percent to 6.8
which is why you've got those interest
rates climbing well CPI has come down uh
and it's good to see uh that coming down
so inflation has come down but we need
to to go further but my focus as health
secretary is on the fourth place cutting
waiting times and just look at the
contrast between England and Wales on
two years weights on 18 month ways well
Wales with a much smaller population has
around 74 000 patients waiting more than
18 months we got that down so below
and I I won't say it's safe for you late
world's got a labor governments on here
you say you want to cut waiting times
one of the ways you're going to cut
waiting times is by having more people
in hospitals more doctors and nurses
because that's a control Factor
um
wants to reduce the number of people
coming into the country let's just first
ask you this
um do you think that people who voted
brexit understood that when you said
Take Back Control that meant uh
controlling immigration to the highest
net number in our history 606
000 this week well as a brexiteer when
people talked about taking back control
it was about the ability to decide who
we bring in and what works best for our
economy and that's why we are expanding
the medical Workforce more than 5 000
doctors
saying that they were saying to control
in order to bring it down not to get to
six hundred years to things like stop
the the small boats and the illegal
migration legal migration
but on doctors we you're right we do
need more doctors and nurses in our
hospitals that's why we've got over 5000
more doctors over 11 000 more nurses
than this time last year so we are
increasing our Workforce Now part of the
So when you say that when you say that
to the Home Secretary she says oh
absolutely Stephen absolutely I
completely agree what we need to do is
to make sure that even though I'm going
to bring the numbers down to she said
last year less than a hundred thousand
we're going to make sure we have more
doctors well the Home Secretary is
absolutely right on the need to bring
the numbers down and the Prime Minister
uh reaffirmed his commitment to bringing
the overall numbers down I think there's
a distinction to draw between for
example some of the abuse of student
Roots people coming in on a student visa
and then changing looking at the number
of dependents and we announced this week
a tightening of controls particularly
where people are coming on undergraduate
student courses and dependents are
coming as well so there's areas of
course the numbers have spiked because
of Ukraine and Hong Kong more than a
hundred thousand from you yeah come on
over 50 and I think that's something
most people actually welcome and accept
come on but it has been come on well the
ons no no you're one of the few
politicians that I know can actually add
up you can do maths you reduce the
numbers from 600 000 to up below 100 000
half a million uh people out of the
immigration figures where are your
doctors and nurses going to come from
well if you have if you're if you're
stopping half a million people we're
confusing nurses are you I think we're
confusing two different things so
firstly 600 000 legal migration which
includes your doctors and nurses I think
as the ons themselves said there was a
spike because of Ukraine on Hong Kong
which I think most viewers except was
the responsible thing for the UK
when you strip out the I think it's
about 320
000 ukrainians and Hong kongers he's
still got more than four or five hundred
thousand well which is why on Tuesday
the Home Secretary announced a
tightening of the rules particularly
around dependence of students looking at
some of the enforcement of our students
so there's things there I think in terms
of the medical community and the NHS
it's two things we do need instructional
recruitment that is something that the
NHS has already always relied on but we
also need to grow our domestic Supply
and that's what the long-term Workforce
plan which quite rightly you highlighted
earlier is by throwing guys all right
look before I let you go uh I'm sorry to
say this but there's one person who can
see never seem to uh get out of the news
and that is your former prime minister
Boris Johnson
um
is it all over for him he claimed he
says that the uh claims that are uh
being made about yet new issues for him
are all nonsense
um he's got his hand over the cabinet
office has to hand over uh the
unredacted WhatsApp messages from him to
the covert inquiry and he's now got
himself a new legal team so it's all a
terrible mess but is Boris Johnson toast
now no I think Boris has a huge role to
to play we saw his leadership in the
country's response to Ukraine where he
took the the lead on that I think that
yeah but we saw a lot of other things
but I just want to talk to you about
where Boris Johnson is now do you want
him back in the next Parliament uh of
course I want all my colleagues back in
the next party Johnson to be back as a
as MP for Uxbridge all the distractions
and we're talking about him now of
course I I want to see Boris back uh as
a member of Parliament and I want
the covenants for the the Prime Minister
that's above my pay grade but the point
is uh you know voice achieved many
things the the speed of the the the
covid roll out so look at our response
in Ukraine if I take my announcement
this week the new hospitals program the
40 new hospitals was something he has
championed including uh for Hillingdon
in his own constituency so so there's
many things that I've worked with with
Boris so you so you're signing up to
bring back Boris uh campaign are you
trying to characterize things in in
different ways what I'm saying is within
the house fear what I am focused on is
empowering patients more that's why we
made the announcement this week on
patient choice but also getting that
investment into the NHS estate and we
also have the four new hospitals
announcement which is the biggest
investment of capital in our NHS uh
Hospital estate over 20 billion pounds
Steve Barkley thank you very much indeed